Speaker 1: The problems will not stop for
Donald Trump's former supposed fraud lawyer,
Sidney Powell.
Now, why do I say suppose it?
Well, you guys, if you've been following the
story, I've been telling you about this story
for a year now.
Sidney Powell.
Appeared to be representing Donald Trump in
various of these frivolous voter fraud.
Motions and complaints filed to courts after
the 2020 election.
But when she got really cuckoo for cocoa puffs,
the White House put out the Trump.
The then Trump White House put out a statement
saying What she's doing, she's doing on her
own.
And then she was banned from the Oval Office,
but was reportedly seen there anyway, etc.
OK.
The latest is that she is now under federal
investigation.
Feds are now asking questions about Sidney
Powell and her pro-Trump group.
Now the details are interesting and you'll
see why in a moment.
The Daily Beast reports.
Ever since Sidney Powell spearheaded one of
then-President Trump's efforts to nullify
the election, she has found herself on the
wrong side of a flurry of potentially ruinous
lawsuits.
But this is not the only part of her deepening
troubles.
For months, the federal investigation running
out of Washington, D.C. has been demanding
documents and asking potential witnesses about
Powell, according to three people familiar
with the matter.
Separately, similarly, a separate investigation
into Powell's anti-democratic activities took
place in the Sunshine State earlier this year
and has already produced results and punished
Powell and her far right group.
The federal probe, which has not been previously
reported, is examining the finances of defending
the Republic, an organization founded by Powell
to fund her lawsuits to overturn the 2020
election, according to two of the people familiar
with the matter.
A grand jury was impaneled and subpoenas and
documents, subpoenas and document requests
have gone out to multiple individuals as recently
as September.
Defending the republic's finances have already
prompted an investigation and a settlement
with Florida's charity regulator.
They paid a $10000 fine in secretly recorded
conversations released by erstwhile Powell
ally Lin Wood over the last few days.
Former Overstock.com and defending the Republic
CEO Patrick Byrne accused Powell of pocketing
funds from the group in order to pay for her
defense against that billion dollar defamation
suit filed by Dominion Voting Systems.
They haven't responded to the comments, so
this is very, very interesting because this
is about the financing of the nonprofit meant
to fight the election results, not about her
completely outrageous participation in perpetuating
the Big Lie with the frivolous, bogus legal
challenges against it.
So it's related to the insanity she was involved
in.
But it's actually about the financing of that
insanity, not the insanity itself.
And of course, she may face disbarment and
all sorts of other problems going forward
as well.
But it's about the funding of those actions,
not the actions themselves.
She seems quite troubled.
As a reminder, here was this very strange
interview that she did with Sarah Ferguson.
We looked at this a couple of months ago.
Speaker 3: Let's get a few simple facts straight.
How many states were Smartmatic machines and
software used in the 2020 election?
Speaker 4: I don't even know the exact numbers.
No idea.
Speaker 3: But you were making some big statements,
very dramatic critical statements about Smartmatic.
You must have known what their involvement
was in the election.
Speaker 4: Oh, you'd have to go look at our
complaint against fact witness with respect
to the four states that we filed legal complaints
right to get the details of that.
Speaker 3: A Google search would have shown
you that Smartmatic was operating in one single
county in California.
Speaker 4: I'm saying I think their involvement
is probably a lot bigger than that.
Speaker 3: What research or fact checking
did you do at the time to find out what Smartmatic
actual involvement in the election was?
Speaker 4: If you work for Smartmatic?
Speaker 3: You've made an allegation against
Smartmatic that they stole a presidential
election.
I think it's incumbent on both of us to know
what Smartmatic involvement was.
It seems like a pretty foundational fact.
I mean,
Speaker 4: I'm confused right now about why
you're here, because how
Speaker 1: did you get into my house, ma'am?
Speaker 3: A series of very strong allegations
against Smartmatic and against Dominion, containing
many errors of fact.
Do you accept the fact now that the company
that you accused of stealing a national election
only operated in one county in L.A., in California,
one county in one state?
Speaker 4: No, I'm not prepared to accept
that fact.
I think Smartmatic involvement was far more
significant than that.
Do I think they're trying to minimize their
involvement?
Of course I
Speaker 3: do.
You said that Smartmatic owns Dominion.
How do you justify such a basic factual error?
Speaker 4: I'm going to start this interview.
Speaker 1: So anyway, who could have predicted
that this entire thing she got involved in
would have backfired horribly?
So now under federal investigation, and I
mean, I wonder if you ask her, do you regret
even getting involved in this stuff? Trump
abandoned you, your legal trouble, federal
investigations, humiliating interviews.
My instinct is she's not so diluted that she
would say, no, it was all worth it.
My instinct is she would say it wasn't worth
it.
It wasn't worth it.
But we may never know.
We'll take a quick break and we will be back
right after this insane new revelations about
COVID during the last presidential campaign
involving Donald Trump and Joe Biden.
Incredible, incredible revelations from Mark
Meadows.
Stay with us!
It isn't an insane story, but a completely
predictable one